hi
and thanks for coming to my talk
so the title of the talk is comparing
computational entropies below majority
or when is the dense model theorem false
and this is based off of joint work with
my advisor
uh russell and pacquiao
so the starting point for this work is
is something called the dense model
theorem and this is a result in
pseudorandomness with kind of a
surprising number of applications to
different areas
so the first context that appeared in
was additive number theory and here
um and and this was due to green tau and
ziggler and they used this to study uh
kind of the presence of arithmetic or
maybe generalized arithmetic
progressions
or some some types of generalizations of
arithmetic regressions in
the prime numbers
um okay and this was later
imported kind of to the theoretical
computer science community
by rheingold trevis and tulsiani and
vadon
and they observed kind of a consequence
in sparse graph regularity
so there was also uh
applications of this idea to
computational notions of differential
privacy
and and this rheingold at all paper also
uh observed a number of interesting
connections
uh between the dense model theorem and
hardness amplification
and and and that will be uh discussed in
a fair bit more detail
okay so now i'll uh describe what
the spinal theorem actually says
um okay so we start with a small set
and this is over a finite universe u
okay
and and here on the picture on the
bottom maybe you know
s is is sparse and simpsons
um and what the dense model theorem does
is it gives us sufficient conditions
for s to have a so-called dense model
and what i mean by that is there'll be
some set
m which is large or maybe we might say
dense and it's indistinguishable from s
according to some tests f okay
and that's what i mean by modeling
so so m kind of looks like s
according to f and these tests will just
take
points in the universe and produce some
value between 0 and 1.
okay so to formalize this we'll just
introduce a definition so two random
variables
x and y over u are epsilon
indistinguishable
with respect to uh this test class f
whenever this quantity here uh is
bounded
by epsilon and and so what's this
quantity so
um well on the inside this is just
saying what is the difference
between kind of the average value of f
over
x and the average value of f over y okay
and and so for this entire quantity to
be small would mean that kind of every f
in in big f um kind of
doesn't have uh doesn't kind of assign
significantly more weight uh or
significantly more mass to x
um than y
um okay so so bringing this uh
definition back
to our informal description from earlier
um so
the death's bottle theorem gives
basically sufficient conditions for s to
have
a a delta dense epsilon model
okay in in by delta dense what i mean as
just
simply that kind of drawing a random
point in the universe
you'll get something that lands in the
set with probability least delta
and by epsilon model i mean kind of in
terms of this indistinguishability that
we just defined so i want to say that s
and
m are epsilon and distinguishable by f
and we might shorthand that by saying m
is kind of an epsilon model of s with
respect to m okay
and i'll mention that this uh this idea
of of having a delta dense model is is
equivalent to this to
um to a notion called the hill
pseudoentropy
okay and this was uh used at least
implicitly
in in hostile pagliatzo loop 11
to construct prgs from one-way functions
and it was considered kind of more
explicitly in
in um paper by barak shaltil and
winderson
okay so now um you know so we've
discussed kind of what the conclusion
means to have a delta dense model now
now i now we need to kind of talk about
uh what these actually sufficient
conditions are
okay so um kind of at a high level the
sufficient conditions
for s are going to just be weaker
pseudorandomness conditions
um with respect to a new test class f
prime um a parameter
epsilon prime a non-negative parameter
and as well as kind of our delta from
before okay
and so we'll define f prime in terms of
a function uh
ge which will take k points in zero one
and
and map to an output in zero one and f
prime will just simply be kind of the
composition of g with elements in f so
what i mean is just you pick
k elements in f excuse me and
um and then you apply g uh to to their
uh evaluations okay and two
examples that are worth keeping in mind
are g being
a product okay and and this will uh
and and and this was used in uh maybe
kind of the green tab setting
um and majority and this was used kind
of in the rttv or wrangled at all
setting
okay and in this latter case we're
thinking of uh maybe
um our f's as being boolean valued so
that way
uh you know g's domain is boolean
okay so um okay so
so uh kind of continuing
what we want these sufficient conditions
to capture is
is something that intuitively will say
that s basically looks delta dense
to f prime and with some error tolerance
epsilon prime okay and and of course
kind of looking delta dense
this can't just mean having a delta
dense model
because uh then we wouldn't have
anything to prove
okay and it turns out that there are two
uh
kind of different sufficient conditions
which work um
the first one uh also kind of the
uh what was used in green tau and
tazzigler
then has a shortcoming of kind of
of of of requiring that epsilon prime
is is exponentially small or the
parameters epsilon
and delta okay um and so this is
is kind of uh you know a a
a weak point of of this particular
formulation of the dense model theorem
or the you know the particular
formulation by
green tau and ziegler
[Music]
and the second sufficient condition
[Music]
is able to get epsilon prime to not be
so small but but in order to do so it
will actually need to
use g which is a majority so recall kind
of earlier g
or like in this case g is actually going
to just be a product
um but now epsilon prime will kind of be
epsilon delta
okay and so what we'll so kind of uh you
know kind of skip it to the punch line
uh we'll actually show that this type of
trade-off between epsilon prime and
g is actually necessary
okay so now i'd like to
try to motivate um studying the
trade-off between g and epsilon prime
um by looking at
an application and de-randomization
um so
so to begin so a major problem
uh in a major kind of guiding question
and complexity
is is basically to build pseudorandom
generators for
small circuits
yes this is not
okay so next i want to motivate
the dense model theorem a little bit
more from the point of view
of uh building pseudorandom generators
so in this situation we'll have er er
so our universe will just be the
n-dimensional hypercube
and our tests will be small circuits
okay and and so one of the kind of major
problems and complexities
is to build pseudorandom generators for
small circuits and by pseudorandom
generator i mean
a excuse me a
um a function g which will take
as so-called like seed
um of length s and it'll map it to some
output of length n
and the hope will be that if i look at
kind of the
distribution that g induces
on the n-dimensional cube when we apply
a uniformly random c to g we'd like this
to actually be
kind of epsilon indistinguishable from
the uniform distribution over the cube
at least according to these tests f okay
and this has uh you know the the the
kind of
most you know famous application of this
is dear randomization of bpp
okay and one of the primary approaches
that have been that's been studied
is kind of this hardness versus
pseudorandomness
idea and here what we would do is start
with
a hard function f and it
and by hard i mean that kind of no small
circuit
can can uh can compute f
um at more than say a gamma fraction of
the inputs
and um here i'm you know this
probability is just the counting measure
okay and um it said this
you know so kind of uh this is studied
kind of both
cryptographic and in these
de-randomization settings is to
is to build cereal generators out of um
hard functions okay
so uh one of the kind of main successes
of this line of inquiry uh is
uh well i mean it is de-randomizing bpp
from destroying enough circular bound
um and the kind of you know
a partial a partial view of the of the
framework
is is they basically start with a
function which we'll just think of as
being delta hard so they can really
start with a worst case hard function
but we'll just think of delta
and and so one step
and this was kind of accomplished at
least for the purposes of de-randomizing
bpp um inaudible simplification step
and hardness amplification will
basically take a delta heart function
and it'll
produce a function which is
significantly
harder but but oftentimes
we'll think of maybe the hardness as
being with respect to a slightly smaller
test class
okay and then it's known you know it's
been known
from the since the paper that nissan
whitnerson how to
actually produce a prg from a
sufficiently good
um average case hardness lower bound
okay
so an interesting kind of property of
this
uh of this approach
is that it uh it kind of incurs
this necessary computational overhead
when we do this hardness amplification
part
so specifically or at least one way of
understanding this computational
overhead
is that in order for this hardness
amplification step to work
we need to basically start with a class
f
which is closed undertaking majority
okay and
and this follows basically from
uh i mean and so this is true modulo
some um additional details
uh which i'm i'm i'm kind of just
glossing over for now but
but so this type of results is kind of
due to schulte alviola and
and more recently a paper with uh green
virtual tilt and viewfinder
okay um so a reasonable question is to
say like can we avoid this overhead
in case we want to de-randomize classes
which aren't closed under majority
um and one uh you know one suggestion
i'll uh make for now is is a
uh an approach of sudan travison and
vidan
and what they do is they start with the
same hypothesis of having a delta heart
function
but now instead of doing hardness
amplification they'll actually
produce a set which is indistinguishable
from a delta density
so in particular they'll produce a set
with a dense model
okay and once they have a set with a
density model
they show that actually applying a
randomness extractor will produce a
pseudorandom generator
um a you know maybe an additional
suggestion
uh which which is worth making at least
in this context
is we could also imagine maybe starting
with some s which satisfies that's model
theorem hypothesis
um use the dense model theorem to
translate it into
one of these delta dense sets and then
apply the extractor
and and so i've kind of glossed over the
extractor part but but the point is is
that
we really can't we don't like in order
for the extractor part to work it needs
to be
a delta dense epsilon model okay
and and this is kind of uh like so we
can't really have a weaker notion
right as far as as far as we know we
can't really have a weaker notion of
computational entropy
and that we can extract from to get
pseudo-randomness
um okay and the
uh you know connecting
this picture back to our work um
we're able to show that kind of
similar to the overhead that's necessary
for hardness amplification
there's also going to be some barriers
to implementing this
these these these other strategies below
majority as well
okay and and this
[Music]
is relevant if we're say trying to
construct pseudorandom generators for
ac zero mod 2.
okay so now uh having
given some background and motivation
i'll i'll describe
the death model theorem in some more
detail
so kind of starting with the conclusion
we're looking for a delta dense epsilon
model
and we have three sets of parameters
and the kind of green parameters are the
are the inputs so
um so this is kind of what we start with
and so s is kind of the set we want to
model
this output if there is one is is just
going to be the dutch model
and then these preconditions are kind of
the important part as far as
the sufficient conditions are concerned
so the preconditions will say
kind of given sf epsilon and delta
uh how and kind of what types of
pseudorandomness conditions does
s need to satisfy um in order for the
dense model theorem to be true
um okay so the first uh
condition of this type uh and this was
the assumption that was used in uh
green tao and the related work with
ziegler
[Music]
so their assumption was that s
is basically delta dense inside of a
pseudorandom set
okay and by pseudo-random set i mean so
there's going to be some set
t and it'll have the property that it's
basic
it's epsilon prime indistinguishable
from the uniform distribution
with respect to these tests f prime and
additionally
s will be delta dense in this set so if
i draw a random element from
t i'll get an elementary mass with red
blue at least delta
okay so this is the first sufficient
condition
the second sufficient condition is known
um so i'll refer to it as epsilon
delta pseudo density in this condition
uh can be phrased in a number of
equivalent ways
but um but but so i'll define it in the
following way
so so s a so a set s will have
epsilon del epsilon prime delta pseudo
density
uh with respect to this test class
f prime if if basically i can
build a delta dense
set which fools any particular f prime
or f and f prime into thinking that it's
s
and so so specifically so you
um so basically i'll give you an f prime
and f and f prime and using knowledge of
f prime you can
all you need to do is construct a delta
that's set so that
f can't tell the difference between s
and m so basically
you know their their their expectations
are close
okay um so this seems like a you know
kind of uh perhaps a pretty weak
condition given that the
set gets to depend on f um but it turns
out
to work to apply the dense model theorem
kind of with the right
restrictions on f prime and f okay
so uh okay so using this picture
i'll kind of maybe try and summarize uh
the difference model theorems
um uh now using this uh table
okay so so once again uh there are kind
of these
two different types of dense model
theorems
generally and the first one basically
makes this dense inside of a
pseudorandom set
assumption it produces it it uses
g which is a product and it uses epsilon
prime which is exponentially small
and the other parameters the
second type of dense model theorem will
now now use this weaker assumption
of pseudo-density um
but the what it needs to pay um
or so it'll use this bigger assumption
of pseudo density and it'll attain an
epsilon prime which is actually going to
be like epsilon times delta
okay but the but it needs to pay in kind
of
how complicated g is so now it needs to
be a majority
okay so before uh
so and so to remind you of our results
we're basically going to be able to show
that you know if we want epsilon prime
to be some polynomial
on epsilon and delta then g will have to
be
relatively complicated so so uh it might
not have to compute majority but at
least you wouldn't be able to do it if
say g was a constant depth circuit
okay
but before discussing
our results in in more detail i want to
kind of explain why you might expect
majority to pop
up when you try to prove the dense model
okay
um so let's just so i'm going to kind of
look
completely hand wave the proof idea
and i mean this isn't really the
complete idea um but but i just want to
give
you just some exposure to what you might
expect majority
okay so um so here we're going to be
trying to
prove that kind of the second sufficient
condition implies a dense model
and we'll actually do it by the
contrapositive so we'll assume that
there
are there aren't any dense models and
then we want to show that the
the second the second condition is
violated okay
so when you write down the definition uh
or you know
what it means to not have a dense model
this is what you get so
so every delta dense set has some
distinguisher between s and m
okay and the kind of crucial observation
is that we can apply lp duality uh
to this statement so we can basically
think about this as a game
and the game is between the measure
player or kind of the model
player and the function player okay um
so by applying lp duality min max or you
know however you'd like to describe it
we can kind of switch the order of play
if we allow
randomization okay so what that means
for us is that
kind of uh under the circumstance that
we don't have a dense model
it's actually the case that there's
going to be some distribution over
our test class which distinguishes
between
uh s and
uh and every uh delta density m
on average okay so we can kind of switch
the order of the quantifiers in some
sense by by using randomness
um and then to get from here to majority
the idea would be
well we'll sample a bunch of independent
copies
of um
of f tilde so this is a small typos
f tilde um
and and then we basically like to argue
that
if we take the majority of those
independent copies then it will be able
to distinguish s from any delta density
set
okay and the idea there would be using
some type of chernoff bound
uh you know to say that uh you know if i
take a bunch of independent samples then
then kind of the value should still
become
you know should still be very close to
this with high probability
um but so so hopefully that explains why
the majority can come up and and
and maybe you know it was like uh
so somehow uh the majority helps us kind
of
aggregate uh you know maybe these
these observations which are
individually a little bit noisy or
not so useful um
[Music]
and so so what we actually can do is say
that the
the usage of majority um
is uh so so we're not going to be able
to say that it's necessary but we're
going to be able to say
that they're kind of classes which don't
compute majority
for which this actually fails okay
so the first example will be
kind of using the first assumption of
being delta density absolute
pseudo-random set
and it will kind of compare that to
having a dense model
it will show that there are
distributions which satisfy
this hypothesis but fail to satisfy the
conclusion
so in particular we'll build
uh this distribution d1 and it will
be delta dense in an epsilon prime
pseudorandom set and
in this case we're thinking of our tests
as being depth d
circuits with size basically
kind of sub exponential and one and d
one and two d
um and
uh but we'll also be able to show that
this doesn't have a delta dense epsilon
model
and actually it'll just be with respect
to bit tests so bit test will just kind
of
take the input and just output the i f
bit
um our second result uh kind of extends
so so our second result concerns kind of
the comparison between the two types
they're between the two sufficient
conditions
so in fact you can show uh
using kind of one of the equivalent
definitions for pseudo density
that this kind of first condition pretty
readily implies the second condition of
pseudo density okay
and what we show is that this kind of uh
and so you would also see kind of by the
dense model theorem the converse is true
at least when you're closed under
majority
but what we show is that it can also
fail when you're not so we show in ac 0
this can fail so ac 0 being
constant depth circuits polynomials so
specifically
we'll again we'll construct a pseudonym
set and it'll be pseudo-dense against
step these circuits of
of a size you know kind of
exponential and maybe 1 and um
and the it will also be able to maintain
that it doesn't have a delta density uh
it's not delta dense in any epsilon
pseudo-random set where now
the tests can compute kind of the parity
of any two bits
so our next result it kind of can extend
or concerns a different model of
computation
and so here we'll also be able to
separate
the sufficient condition these two
sufficient conditions and but now it
will be with respect to low degree
polynomials so what we can
show is that we we can find sets which
are pseudodense for low degree
polynomials
and here the field really doesn't matter
i'm just that it's finite and its
characteristic is constant
and uh but you know we'll simultaneously
get the property that's not delta dense
in any epsilon pseudo-random set
uh again with respect to these kind of
parity of two bits tests
finally we we can prove a slightly more
general result
which which says that
if if we have a test class f so that we
couldn't
use kind of f oracle gates in a in a
constant depth circuit which solve
majority
then it actually will have a pseudo
density
of this type okay and then we can use
and then
and then once again we can finally send
that to say that it's not delta dense
and epsilon zero
and this um you know will this is going
to draw heavily from
from the work of schulte and viola who
show something quite similar
uh for hardness amplification
okay so i also want to mention
the relationship between the dense model
theorem and the hardcore dilemma
and part of that is because it will
explain uh some of the motivation in
terms of de-randomization from earlier
okay so the hardcore lemma is kind of a
a classical resultant circuit complexity
and it says that
if we have a n-bit boolean function
which is delta-heart for f-prime
um then there's actually a delta-dense
set
and actually well so it's two dense
thanks to
holmenstein
um on which f is
extremely hard for uh
big f which is we think of is slightly
smaller than f prime and actually we'll
think of
f prime as just being the majority of
f's okay um
so so what does that mean um
it's it says that there's going to be
this this this dead set on which
f on which kind of this big f can't
really do better
at computing f than just guessing a
random bit
okay um and so this can be used say
kind of to prove the you know yaoz xor
lama
um but
uh and another thing worth noting is
that the known proofs
actually do take kind of this f prime uh
to be g to be majority of f's
okay and in fact this is kind of
necessary
uh in some
you know for some kind of formulations
if necessary and this is due to
lutzei wu and schulte
um so the other relevance of the
hardcore lemma
is that it's used in the sudan travis
and vadon construction of the
pseudo-entropy generator from the delta
heart function
okay and the idea is to kind of use the
hardcore
like to use this two delta set m
as kind of
as as the starting point for
our pseudoentropy generator
um okay so this is a the hardcore lemma
um another
[Music]
the thing that kind of ties it directly
to our work is that
is it claimed by pagliatso his claim
says that
if the dense model theorem is true for f
then so is the hardcore lemma okay
and i'm being vague uh but um
but there is a very strong connection
and you know these
the parameters are preserved um and in
particular
this implication means that by
disproving the dense model theorem in
the context we just proved it we also
showed that the hardcore lemma is false
in these contexts
um and as far as i know these are kind
of the first explosive counter examples
to hardcore lemma below majority
that have appeared in the nurture
um okay so
as kind of the last part before
concluding i just wanted to mention
uh just some simple technical ideas that
that
uh that get a lot of mileage in this
paper
um so the first one is relevant to
showing
that uh kind of a particular really
given set x doesn't have a dense model
okay and the way that we do that is
we'll use kind of a necessary condition
of density
so this necessary condition says if we
have a delta dense x
and and uh sorry so so this is over kind
of the n-dimensional hypercube
um then
the kind of average bit of a random
string from the set
is going to be close to a half and and
kind of
its closeness will be kind of determined
by delta n in this way
okay so so maybe it's easier to see what
this means by a picture so the idea is
like
um so say we're kind of building a delta
then
set x and we want to do it
in a way that maintains that the bits
are as biased as possible
okay so so what we would probably start
doing is
you know start at kind of one of the
ends of the cube and start packing it
and packing it and packing it
um until basically we got to like
delta okay and the question
is uh you know like how how far
do we get um and in fact we get this far
okay um and
not only that this is actually um
you know kind of the best thing we can
do like so like
uh if we wanted to kind of maximize
the average bias the best thing we could
do is basically pick this half
pick this uh you know kind of hammond
ball but in general
the idea is that since the cube
since so much of the mass of the cube is
very close
to its center um in the sense of very
close to kind of
uh weight on over two strings um
the only way we can pick a lot of
strings is by picking a lot of ones
which are basically
balanced okay and this is
basically a quantification of that and
and it's uh it's also kind of like the
same thing as like
chiang's lemma
uh from analysis bullying functions um
and and and it's been used again so this
observations have been used in their
original places like
uh raz this paper a parallel repetition
uses this idea
um and then another good reference is is
kind of uh or mayer
and whitterson who wrote a whole paper
basically about this
lemma okay so it looks it's a it's a
really nice reference
um so the usefulness for us is
that if we can design a set
basically where every single bit
so say we have the set like s here
where every single bit uh has kind of
uh is like um is it greater
you know has has epsilon more bias than
this kind of
order square root like 1 and delta over
n then it would mean that s would
actually be indistinguishable or epsilon
or epsilon distinguishable or rather by
by any delta density set x
okay
so the hope would be we want to say
there are kind of
sets s where every bit is very biased
or you know kind of extremely biased um
but it still is actually uh pseudo then
so it still satisfies this like weaker
pseudorandomness condition okay so that
would so this would kind of be
the basic ideas is to use this idea
um of constructing biased sets
um so in order to extend this to saying
that x is intense in a pseudo-random set
we want we what we'll basically do is
extend the previous observation
uh to use kind of concentration and now
instead of looking for biased set
bias that's what we'll look for is kind
of sets which put a large mass on their
tails
and by that i mean kind of like uh the
tails of the random variable
kind of x uh sum of the x i's is heavy
okay
um so we also need to kind of prove
these unconditional pseudo-density
results
and the way that we do that is by uh
or so one way of framing that is we kind
of solve this relative error version
of the so-called coin problem and the
coin problem is something that's
received a lot of attention recently
uh in the pseudorandomness literature
and
this uh part will kind of we end up
using
um drawing a lot from the work of
saltillo viola srinivasan
and uh tall okay
so now i'm concluding i'll
i guess i'll just ask maybe three
questions which
i'd like to know some more about um
so the first is can we extract basically
pseudo randomness from pseudo density
okay um so so recall that like stv
showed that we can extract
from dense models
but we showed here that you know in
order to go from pseudo density dense
models you need to pay a majority
okay so can we just uh avoid that
and just extract directly from
pseudo-density so this was
so this has been studied recently um uh
it's
two very nice papers so deron moskowitz
oh zuckerman and chad and tell so
so they study this question uh in when
they're trying to get
a kind of super efficient hardness to
randomness tradeoffs
okay so the second question is is just
whether hardness amplification is
actually just
false under majority um so we know
from this work that the hardware limit
is false in some cases
um and we also know
you know a lot of limitations of
hardness amplification
related to majority from the work of
saltillo and viola
and grinberg voltilviola but we'd like
to know
could you just prove unconditionally
that this type of amplification
couldn't work okay and finally um
are the hardcore lemon and the dust
model theorem equivalent so
recall kind of
bugliatzo shows that the hardcore lemma
implies the dense model theorem
but uh the other direction is still not
known
um okay so that concludes the talk and
thanks for listening